Ta-da!
Hello, nice to meet you!
I am Netflix's official VTuber,
N-ko.
My full name is
N-ko Mei Kurono.
I'm a sheep-human lifeform born in California.
I am Netflix Anime Club's manager, and I love anime.
My mission concerns
shows streaming on Netflix:
the fun anime and movies,
to let many more people know about them.
To accomplish my mission,
I, N-ko,
am played by one of Netflix's employees.
I am played by an employee,
who knows the contents very well.
That's why I can tell you the charm of our anime
very thoroughly.
I cannot tell you much about the details of the work I usually do,
but I have meetings with offices around the world,
and make various adjustments at work
to make the anime even more appealing.
I'll tell you a little bit more about myself.
I love singing, dancing and getting a massage,
but I don't like writing kanji,
and anything that contains elements of horror.
On my days off, I often hang out with my friends.
Regarding anime I like,
I can't finish talking about them in this video,
so I'll do that later as the project proceeds.
Oh, also,
I was born and raised in America,
so I can speak in both Japanese and English.
I'll introduce myself briefly in English too.
Hi, my name is N-ko Mei Kurono.
I'm a sheep-human lifeform,
born in California.
I'm Netflix Anime's new brand ambassador
who, of course, loves anime.
Basically, from among the various shows streamed on Netflix,
I'll introduce anime I recommend
in the videos I upload,
which hopefully will make you interested in them.
Also, I will do collabs with my VTuber seniors,
and I'd like to try covering songs and do game commentaries too.
Also, I would like to be friends with my viewers watching this now,
so please use hashtags on Twitter,
or leave me comments on YouTube.
I'm waiting for many messages from you.
Please ask me questions on Twitter
or in my YouTube videos' comment section.
To spark your interest in Netflix itself as a company,
I'll be telling you information that only employees know,
so please look forward to it.
Well, my greetings to you, again.
I look forward to seeing you in the future.
See you!